[Musique]
c'est avec vous Anthony Saint-Léger
bonjour bonjour et d'après plusieurs
publications à la politique zéro covid
qu'on évoquait à l'instant prenait par
la Chine aurait un impact jusque dans
les tribunes des stades du Mondial au
Qatar effectivement un peu de contexte
d'abord la Chine est confrontée depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant à un
mouvement de contestation vague et
plutôt inédit en la raison ce sont ces
mesures sanitaires à draconiennes
imposée par Pékin depuis maintenant près
de trois ans en deux mots ce sont des
tests quasi journalier des confinement
sans fin et un port du masque
obligatoire et justement cacher ce
masque que je ne saurais voir nous dit
certains internautes qui assurent que la
Chine a cherche à cacher à ces
téléspectateurs le fait que des
supporters sont masques sont présents
dans les tribunes des stades du Mondial
et pour preuve en serait cette vidéo que
l'on voit ici et qui a été partagé qui a
dépassé le million de vues on a
différentes captures d'écran que je vais
vous montrer et dans cette vidéo ce sont
en fait différentes scènes de différents
matchs il y a par exemple ici Pays-Bas
Sénégal ou encore ici États-Unis Pays de
Galles et à chaque fois vous le voyez
que ce sont tous les supporters qui sont
floutés pas uniquement donc ce sans
masque alors info ou un toc c'est bien
on va regarder de plus près justement
l'une de ces captures d'écran il y a un
indice qui va attirer notre attention il
se trouve ici c'est un nom d'utilisateur
d'un compte do Youn pardon le TikTok
chinois m'est réservé aux publics
chinois puisque Tik Tok et réservé et
bien chinois mais réservé au public
international et en l'occurrence celui
de la chaîne young shipping une chaîne
chinoise qui appartient au China Media
Group et cette vidéo virale on ne la
retrouve absolument pas sur le compte de
la chaîne en question en revanche elle a
publié des extraits de match sans aucun
floutage c'est le cas par exemple de
Pologne Mexique d'Argentine Arabie
Saoudite d'Angleterre Iran et d'ailleurs
cette même chaîne a publié l'intégralité
du replay du match États-Unis Pays de
Galles dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure et qui est mentionné dans la
vidéo virale et vous voyez ici le
comparatif entre ceux de la vidéo virale
entièrement flouté et ce effectivement
qui ont été publiés par la chaîne en
question donc pas flouté la vidéo virale
n'est donc qu'un grossier montage pas de
censure sur Internet a priori donc mais
qu'en est-il de la télévision Anthony et
bien pour répondre à cette question on a
regardé là télévision et on a comparé
deux choses on a comparé d'abord ce qui
se passait ici en France et ce qui se
passait sur 6 City TV5 plus plus
précisément la version Sport finalement
de la chaîne chinoise à Sissy TV la
chaîne d'État et ce à plusieurs reprises
par exemple prenons le match d'hier
entre la France et la Tunisie un match
en direct comme on a regardé en direct
les deux chaînes présentaient les mêmes
images en direct donc au même moment
pour ce qui est des replays maintenant
ça se complique grâce à l'aide de notre
correspondant à Shanghai Antoine Morel
on a pu établir quelques subtilités par
exemple pour le match d'ouverture
Qatar Équateur il n'y avait aucune coupe
entre les deux les deux chaînes aucune
coupe donc de la part de si si TV en
revanche d'autres rencontres ont été
censurées en partie c'est le cas par
exemple ça a commencé nous dit notre
correspondant avec Pays de Galles
États-Unis c'était le 29 novembre c'est
le cas aussi avec France Danemark
regardez on va tout simplement faire un
comparatif ici vous avez la 23e minute
sur la chaîne française là où sur la
chaîne chinoise vous vous retrouvez avec
un plan de Didier et Deschamps le
sélectionneur français de même le plan
de pelouse à la 43e minute est en fait
celui qui alors j'ai retrouvé l'image de
base ce serait mieux voilà
la 43e minute ici sur une chaîne
française ici sur la chaîne chinoise
remplacez donc par un plan de pelouse il
y a bien censure donc mais vous l'aurez
compris pas de manière systématique
alors comment expliquer cette différence
et bien l'hypothèse la plus probable
c'est tout simplement que le match
d'ouverture a permis de montrer qu'il y
avait des supporters sans masque et que
consécutivement la Chine a décidé de
censurer en partie en partie parce que
au fil des rencontres elle a vu aussi la
réaction des médias internationaux qui
précisément évoquaient cette censure et
donc à changer son fusil d'épaule
apparemment merci Anthony Saint-Léger
c'était un foin tox avec Anthony rester
avec nous dans trois minutes un nouveau
journal dans Paris direct
[Musique]